[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michelle tafoya i believe worked her
300th game on an nfl sideline this past
november
and uh she'll have that opportunity to
be there
in buffalo with the ravens and the bills
coming up this saturday night also
second episode of season two of nbc
sports
sports uncovered the podcast series
hosted by michelle
debuts today featuring gail sierens who
in december of 1987
became the first woman to call an nfl
game handling play-by-play duties that
was the seahawks and chiefs
that nbc podcast episodes available
for download we bring in michelle tafoya
give me a weather update weather
forecast here
michelle it is definitely uh soup
weather so minestrone or minestrone
how do you decide if you're going to go
minestrone or minestrone
i thought it was minestrone am i just
stupid don't answer
you know like obviously well no you went
to berkeley didn't you you went to cal
state i went i went to dayton so i
i go mineostrone but i don't know
minestrone sounds like what i would say
growing up in the midwest where
menestrone
sounds like maybe somebody who's a
little bit more educated palette
well you know what uh let's let's find
out let's let somebody
be an expert on this and tell us because
i've always heard minister oni
but you know what what do i know i know
that whatever
the sky right now in buffalo outside my
hotel room looks a little soupy
it's gonna be cold and it's gonna be
windy the um
the snow might not start until the
second half that's what it's showing
right now but either way
uh that could make this really
interesting
what's it like though when it does snow
you're covering the game
and normally you'd be on the sidelines
but what is that like when those
conditions
uh present themselves because it's cold
and stupid and and you're just going
what you know
it's worse rain is worse because you
have to juggle an umbrella in your hand
your notepad your microphone you feel
like you can't hold on to anything
tightly and you're just fumbling those
items the whole entire game
so snow is a little easier the wind
is not fun but yeah we're in that moat
they call it that first row of the
stands
and uh you just i don't know you just
deal with it
lots of warmers what uh worst weather
you ever uh
were reporting it oh my gosh i mean
i would say no matter what it was rain i
did a game at
i want to say it was mississippi state
or ole miss and i'm sorry that i'm
confusing the two this was so long ago i
know i was in mississippi
and we had like seven overtime or
something because of the rain
so you know it just it just no one could
win the game
that was a bad one but uh you know it is
what it is
do you have a signature play that you
remember that you covered a game and you
were
that you'll be able to tell your kids
kids that you were there
seeing that firsthand you know there are
quite a few but the one that jumps to
mind is the malcolm butler interception
in the super bowl against
seattle and i would happen to be
standing behind bill belichick when it
happened
and i'll just never forget the shock of
it the shock that they threw the ball
the shot that he picked it
at the time no one knew who malcolm
butler was and then seeing
because i was staying you know my my
vision included
belichick and his arms go way up in the
air in this like victory sign
it was i mean that visual for me is uh
will never leave me
i was right by the goal post and so
yeah because i was presenting the trophy
and i'm thinking seattle's going to win
the super bowl marshawn lynch is going
to
run right in front of me and
as russ went back to pass i went oh no
and i'm standing next to ron vacaro who
is you know great producer on football
night in america i go oh no
and then through the ball and i go oh my
god okay at least they knocked it down
and then malcolm butler pops up and i go
so i have to start taking inventory of
who i'm going to interview on the podium
i'm thinking is paul allen going to be
down here i got pete carroll
who's the mvp next thing i know is
malcolm butler just made the greatest
play in super bowl history
yeah is he going to be the mvp and then
like it was just it was one of those
weird moments there and then the other
one was roethlisberger
when he threw the touchdown pass to win
the super bowl to beat arizona
i'm right there in the corner because i
have to go out on the podium
again i think arizona is going to win it
like
you know is mr bidwell going to be on
the podium uh
like you who's the mvp like it's just
it's kind of crazy
in those moments then you have to still
do your job
yeah well that's the funny part is yeah
you're prepping for a post-game
interview or in your case the trophy
presentation
and suddenly your whole mind has to
shift and i
i went through the same thing my job
after malcolm butler made that
interception was to not lose
sight of the kid so i'm like literally
stalking the sideline
every move he made i made you know
behind the bench
and then of course when i finally grab
him right after the game
and they're taking their time getting it
down to me and finally when al
throws to me you know he's now let's go
to michelle in that
instant malcolm butler decides i've
waited long enough i'm taking off
he takes off i have to chase him down
and it's i've never looked back at it
i'm told it's kind of humorous but
we did i chased him down i got him on
camera uh
but yeah you know that that was kind of
remarkable
but you've chased people down you don't
know you're on camera like we can
sometimes see
the wide shot of the field when the game
is over
and then all of a sudden we we can see
you like
it probably gets physical where you got
to box out people don't you
oh there's no question this job is way
more physical not so much this year
because we don't have that
space to cover but it's way more
physical than people realize the running
around that you do
half time chasing coaches the whole bit
i also marvel though when you have to
talk to a coach who's lost and it's a
big game
and yeah and trying to find just the
sensitivity level
you know it's a completely different
tone
totally like how do you you know you you
almost have to gear up
for it because you almost have to feel
their pain put yourself in there
and i don't know what is your process
you're spot on
you're spot on with that good for you
dan
you want to come up to buffalo and work
this game because you've got it all
figured
out no i i'm gonna watch i'm gonna
i you know if the game was in tampa then
i might go but no not
oh yeah yeah buffalo well you know you
do you gear up because it is a painful
moment
you don't you don't really know how the
coach is going to respond in that moment
and different coaches
are different right so you you
kind of go through your mind about what
do i know about this coach
what do i expect the reaction to be to
my questions
how and it's it's body language it's
tone of voice it's the words you choose
there's a lot that goes into it but
you're right it is a completely
different interview and
far less fun what is uh the difference
or do you notice a difference in lamar
jackson and or josh allen
at this point this year as opposed to
last year
well i think i think just on the
football field lamar is
just a better passer than he has been
and also he's
a better decision maker than he has been
and i would say some of the same things
for
for josh that you know the the accuracy
was the question he seems to have gotten
that
uh on track and and just his ability to
make the right decisions but
he's he's got another piece to the
puzzle which is stefan diggs
that makes decision making a whole lot
easier for him so
you know it's been interesting this
draft class of these guys and in their
third seasons a lot of these guys seem
to be turning the corner and we're
looking at uh you know the the next
generation of these quarterbacks are
going to be going up against each other
in playoff games and super bowls and
regular season rivalries and it's
it's really been kind of fun is it
important or how important is it for you
to be involved in
the game plan for both of these like
when al and chris
are there with coaches and is it
important
for you to be listening to what these
teams are trying to do
hoping to do expected to do no question
because when you go to halftime
and you want to talk to these coaches
you need to know
what they were trying to achieve in that
first half you know
at any point in the game what their
mindset was what they were trying to do
who they were trying to get involved who
they were trying to stop you know what
they were trying to do
so because you want those questions at
halftime to give you something now it's
hard to get something
you know really meaty because these
coaches at halftime they're like
just ask me the question and let me go
you know i get it it's
not the place they want to be but if you
i find that if you ask more detailed
questions you're going to get a better
answer and so
um yeah that's absolutely important i
watch chris's tapes he prepares tapes on
every
uh you know every offense and every
defense each week both offenses both
defenses
and and i watch those because they give
you a great sort of education as to
what these teams are good at what
they're not as good at and what you
should be looking for
and contractually do the coaches have to
stop for
two questions you know
i i'm going to be honest with you i
don't know what the contractual thing is
and
with andy reid we have a different
arrangement he he only likes to do those
interviews walking off the field at
halftime if he's a head or tied
and and we accept that well
they all would like that michelle
but he's the one that's made that clear
and we've always honored it
and uh you know so and maybe i shouldn't
have said it because now this is going
to get like distributed to all the
coaches in the nfl and they're going to
say yeah
only um you know
how about this michelle you have to have
a super bowl win
to be able to ask for this how's that
oh yeah let's suppose they're putting
all kinds of restrictions on this thing
that's great
no i think there probably is something
contractual because they do it for every
network they you know they and they do
it for their
usually they do it for their home radio
people too so
um it's there are moments
you're not gonna get hit a home run
every every half time but there are
moments when you get one
and uh you go oh gosh this is great you
know
i always refer back to bill parcells
telling me he was gonna
start tony romo in the second half and
and that was a big big news story so
i was grateful for that one have fun and
uh
you know i i'm rooting for snow i don't
know if you are but
you know fred godelli is oh you know yes
you know he is because there's this
sense that if people see snow
they will stop with their put their
remote down and watch so
yeah but michelle's gonna watch me fred
goodelli
and you know is one of the great
producers uh in
in in this business he's in a truck yes
i know that
so he's not i mean he's rooting for snow
but he he's
he doesn't care about those in the
elements
he just wants it these are pretty
pictures you know what i hear in my ear
every time it's always 70 and perfect
inside the truck and
you know the things i want to say
it's not pretty uh thank you michelle
have fun we'll be watching we appreciate
it as always
thanks dan talk to you later that's
michelle tafoya nbc sunday night
football sideline reporter
but she'll be there on saturday night